JaQuel Knight is the creative mind
behind many of Beyoncé's
iconic performances.
He's worked with her for years
and he's been dancing his entire life.
I remember dancing in my
grandmother's living room.
And then when I was 16, I
started my own dance group
with my best friend in Atlanta.
So that was kinda the first serious step
towards choreography
and creative direction.
At just 18, JaQuel landed a gig
choreographing
one of the best videos of all time.
Single Ladies.
Years later, JaQuel reveals what it takes
to be a back-up dancer for Beyonce.
To work for B as a dancer,
it takes everything,
you know.
She's a southern girl, you know,
who's worked very hard
to get where she is.
So she want people to do the same.
She wanna know that
you want it really bad.
She wanna see your heart,
your passion, your drive.
And then, you know, you
gotta be able to jam.
How greasy can you get?
How can you hit it hard?
Then there's also the side of her
that's looking for the technical element.
You know, are you trained?
Do you have any ballet training?
Do you have any jazz training?
How are your lines?
You know, so there's a few things
that go into the process.
And once we start to
audition things, you know,
we look for everything.
We teach them hip hop number,
we teach them a super
difficult technical number,
we teach them the classic
Beyoncé number, you know.
And then besides that, you know,
you gotta be able to carry
the stage, you know, with her.
You gotta be able to stand next to her
and be just as good, you know.
And sometimes people are
ready, sometimes they're not.
You can be a great dancer,
but it may not come through
when you get on stage.
You may kind of pull into a shell,
don't know who to look at.
So she's looking for stars.
Star dancers, who have magic.
That can bring it, you know,
and pull other people in, always.
Working with B during
the rehearsal process
is like, it's kind of a out
of body experience, ya know.
People don't understand
the amount of effort
her work ethic is out of this world.
And it's never just one thing.
When we're creating
choreography, it's okay, boom.
Where's the wardrobe at?
You know, bring them in so they can see
what the choreography is.
Okay boom.
Where are we on this stage?
You know, let's make sure lighting knows
how to light this, boom.
Where are the cameras?
Okay, let's look at this
camera and then do this.
You know, we're always thinking
of every single piece of the puzzle.
But you know, at the end of the day,
we send her pictures, we send her videos.
She's watching people in rehearsal
like who's that?
Okay, that's so and so
that we talked about.
She's like okay, she's good.
You know, she's looking at everything
at every moment, you know.
So she's like heavily involved.